All right, the third in our trifecta is a somewhat different approach in mRNA-based
generation of a tri-specific. This is Dr. Rodriguez.
So not necessarily a tri-specific, a quad-specific. Yeah, great. So we're going to
shift gears a little bit, and I don't have any data to show, so don't worry about that,
or don't feel disappointed. What I want to do is teach and learn at the same time,
because I had to sit down and read a lot about mRNA and nanolipids. So what I want to do is go
over that and then this mRNA agent. So in our body, we have the DNA that is then transcribed
to messenger RNA, which the ribosomes then transform that into proteins. And in our body
and in myeloma, we're making antibodies, right? So with the bispecifics and the tri-specifics,
the lab or ex vivo, these antibodies. Now with mRNA, now that we have all this experience with
the COVID vaccines, and surprisingly, mRNA has been actually used and studied since the 1960s,
but it didn't really gain a lot of momentum until now that we're in the COVID world.
So how can we actually do mRNA therapy that helps create antibodies in the body?
So for that, we need lipid nanoparticles. And in order to make an mRNA lipid nanoparticle,
you first need to prepare the linearized DNA template. And then you're going to have to
transcribe the mRNA in vitro, and you have to purify it. And then once you have it purified,
you're going to do a rapid mixing. So what you want to do, if you introduce RNA alone into a body,
the body's going to dissolve the RNA, and it's not going to last in the body long.
So we need to cover it with a lipid layer so that that gives the RNA a longer half-life.
So the way to do that is by what's called a rapid mixing. So you have an aqueous phase,
which is the RNA, which is negatively charged. And then you have an organic phase, which is
positively charged. This organic phase is the lipids. And you actually do a rapid mixing. You
throw both of them at the same time. And then you have a rapid mixing. And then you have a rapid
at the same time rapidly. And as a consequence, the lipids organize around the mRNA and make these
capsule. So the core layer, which are the two small circles that you see there, are protecting
the messenger RNA. And then you have an outer layer that's the one that's going to help
with membrane fusions with cells and to increase the half-life of these
nanolipids. So a nanolipid is going to contain the ionizable catonic lipids,
which are the ones that are going to bind to the mRNA. It's going to have the phospholipids
that are going to help with it permeating into membranes and moving across the body.
It's going to have the pegylated lipids, which are going to give it a longer half-life.
And it's going to have the cholesterol lipids, which are going to give it the structure.
And depending on how much cholesterol you put is how big that nanolipid is going to be
and how easily it's going to move in the body from one place to another.
And it's going to inflate the cargo, which is in this case, the mRNA.
So with Moderna, we have a first-in-human study using the studies mRNA-2808, and what it's doing
is that it's developing lipid nanoparticles with four mRNAs. And these four mRNAs are going to
contain three, so three of these mRNAs are going to contain the information to be able to generate
antibodies that are going to target CD3 on the T-cell and are going to target either BCMA,
GPRC5D, or FCRH5. So that is going to give us like a triple target for the myeloma,
and it's at the same time going to bind to the T-cell that's CD3.
This is administered intravenously, and the reason why intravenously is the route chosen is
if you give it intravenously, it's mainly going to concentrate in the liver and in the spleen,
thirdly in the lymph nodes, and then in those cells, the macrophages of the spleen mainly,
then that macrophage is going to use that mRNA to generate these antibodies in the liver.
But the mRNA is not going to integrate into the DNA, so we're not really causing any changes in
the human genome, like other therapies in benign heme where we're actually doing
changes in genetic alteration. And then,
once these cells are producing these antibodies, they're going to secrete these
bispecific T-cell engagers, targeting BCMA, GPRC5D, and FCRH5. So here we see how the structure
of those antibodies and the concept of the mechanism of how it works. And the key thing
is, okay, why are we doing mRNA? I mean, we already have the bispecifics, and we have the
trispecifics, and we already know how to make these antibodies ex vivo. Why go through the
process of doing an mRNA? So there's a few things. One is that with the mRNA, you can actually
deliver multiple targets at once. Instead of having to administer TEC and TAL, or having to
do a trispecific and combine it with another agent, here we have the ability to modify very easily
the number of different mRNAs that we're going to introduce into this nanolipid, and then deliver
three different agents.
At once. So we're delivering any of the BCMAs, whether it be TEC or LIMBO or ELRA, we're delivering
TALC, and we're delivering zivostimab, if we want to call it that way, just to make it simple,
all at once. We don't know the pharmacokinetics. We do not know the onset of action, because we
first need to generate these antibodies, and then that's going to determine
what the CRS pattern and the timing of the CRS is going to be. And the regulatory
pathway is still less established. So we still have a lot to learn. But in preclinical models, with
apes, mouse and mouse models, we are seeing a great signal of these production of these antibodies
and the target in myeloma cells, when these animals are, in fact, are co-cultured with myeloma.
So this first-in-human study is going to help us answer that question. And in summary, this mRNA is
the first of its kind in terms of therapeutic agent in multiple myeloma. It's a novel modality
that enables delivery of multi-agent targeting antibodies in one therapy.
It also has the potential to reduce antigen escape, because you're attacking the myeloma
cell from different angles. And at the same time, it has the potential to simplify production
and cost of antibody therapy, because these are easy to make. They're easy to modify and manipulate
or change. And then we're going to wait for the results, hopefully by next year,
we'll have some data for you guys to show.